hello everyone and welcome to a very
exciting game from round six of the 2019
single kupets witch hunt an island
versus onigiri and the story about the
video freezing all the time in the in
the previous video I have no idea why
this keeps happening I'm gonna have to
get a new PC obviously as this is this
is not the way to go but I will try to
improve on it and and check if the video
lag is before uploading it I usually do
check but I don't check the entire video
I just check a few segments of the video
and then decide to upload it so really
really sorry about that but on the other
hand you also had a chance to to
practice your blindfold analysis so
without further ado Anand vs. Geary
unand opens with the white pieces we
have E 4 and the Giri goes for the
Sicilian defense with c5 Knight to f3 d6
and d4 just the standard stuff with
Knight captures Knight to f6 Knight
captures sorry Knight captures on d4
Knight to f6 Knight to c3 and now Knight
to c6 with a3 are preparing before at
some point with Bishop to e7 and f4 by
Anand with d6 Knight back to f3 avoiding
the trade in the center also preparing
e5 maybe at in some cases with castles
by Gary and Bishop to d3 with a6
preparing b5 castles by Anand and now b5
and here
not allowing black to put before himself
on and pushes b4 and a Giri goes for a 5
as Anand dark square Bishop still isn't
developed Geary can play a 5 and now you
cannot capture and b5 for example if
Knight captures just Punk after some
before and you cannot recapture the
rooks are not connected so after a 5 we
have looked the b1 Geary trades be a
capture some before 8 captures and now
d5 so already give you able to execute
d5 which is of course very good for him
and there is one game in the database
from 1984 where he capture some d5 was
played but on an improves on it with E 5
so it's as of move 14 that we have a
completely new game now here we could go
from night
g4 seems like a nice square for the
night and if Anand wants to get away
from there he's gonna have to further
weaken his King side but Aguirre prefers
the Knights to e8 with Knight captures
on b5 grabbing a pawn but only
temporarily Bishop to e6 by Geary
Knight back the d4 and now Knight
captures on b4 just grabbing that pawn
and now comes Bishop Bishop captures on
a6 but some captures with rook captures
on a6 and now finally after all has been
7 down and the Queen side Island starts
the attack on the Kings side with f5 and
the Giri doesn't like the idea of the
potential f6 so he captures each captors
and f5 the rook can also help out with
the defense but also maybe even as an
attacking piece with Knight captures on
f5 and now Knight back to c7 with c3
preventing d4 also making a nice output
for the knight on d4 Knight to c6 and
now Queen to d3 a very nice move as it
pressure is the h7 phone but also the
rookin is 6 so for example if black
plays something like rook e8 you can
just play captures captures Ruby 7
threatened to capture the night also the
rook will then be vulnerable and white
just gets a whole lot of activity so
Gary gets the rock out of the way right
away rook to a4 and now finally
developing the Bishop Bishop to e3
we have roped efore preparing to capture
on e5 and here Allen plays Bishop to b6
st. agiri if you capture on e5 that's
just bad for example if Knight captures
Knight captures rook captures you win a
pawn but then push it back to d4 and you
lose your look you have to give it up
for the night or or if you try to save
it for example rookie 4 then you get
Queen g3 with the threat of mate and
after Bishop to f6 Knight h6 check King
h8 and now rook captures on f6 and now
comes the beauty after G captures rook
to b8 and now if Queen captures the
Bishop captures and f6 is mate and
whatever well pretty much everything
else you do you you're also getting made
it so quite a nice little line on and
says nope you cannot capture this pawn
heiresses all right with Queen to d7 now
attacking the knight on f5 and here
comes Bishop captures on c7 Queen
captures on c7 and then out comes Queen
captures on d5 getting rid of this pawn
and looked left 4 by Gary
so here Anand has a very nice position a
lot of activity he's up upon and he has
to decide what to do here yesterday I
don't know it was already at this moment
when I saw the position I didn't watch
the game prior to this and I thought wow
what about Queen captures and c6 here it
seems like a nice idea because if King
captures the knight captures with check
pics of the Queen the problem is after
Queen captures on c6 you don't capture
immediately first Bishop c5 check you
get rid of the bishop and now of course
if Queen captures then you lose the
Queen so you block with the knight 93d
for now black captures the Queen now you
cannot recapture the knight is pinned
but now the other night delivers the
fork check and well the Queen is now
under attack by both nights now the
bishop will capture the knight back
Knight captures now white is not up a
piece and after let's say Bishop c5
check your trade off every rooks and
rook c8 white is still up upon but the
black will be able to hold this you will
most likely win the the isolated C pawn
so very nice idea but it doesn't work
and goes night 5 to d4 and here he says
ok I'm threatening to capture your
knight
you could move it prevent me from
pushing something like a 6 by Knights to
d8 but also you can just capture on d4
but by capturing and before you fix my
pawn structure this is what Gary plate
and rook to b8 and now we have Queen -
b7 on and up upon offers a queen trade
with Queen captures rook captures and
now King to a faith defending the bishop
also improving the activity of your King
and here well I don't play the g3 here
and this is not the absolute best way to
go about the position so feel free to
pause the video here and try to figure
out another way to go about the position
while I give you a couple of seconds
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations for excellently going
about the position and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
look the c1 is much stronger threatening
rook to c7 and there you will just have
a whole lot of threats along the seventh
rank for example after black plays g5 he
wants to play h5 g 4 you're gonna play
h3 h 5 and now whatever you can play
east 6 and it's a very hard position
position for black to defend either he
captures and you play Knight e5
threatening IG 6 check to pick up the
bishop black has to defend rook f6 and
now you play rook seat the c7 now you're
threatening to win the bishop either you
were gonna play rook e8 and then face
Knight d6 check which loses the rook or
you're gonna move the bishop let's say
try but sure b6 but then you get Luke to
h7 now the threat is rook to h8 mate and
after King g8 now you play rugby g7
check King to f8 and now finally Knight
to d7 check is sufficient for a win as a
human material and of course of the game
on the other hand after let's say this a
6 move black can play f6 prevent 295
it's not a problem you still play rook
rook over to here threaten the bishop
and after you defend the bishop then you
push d5 you're gonna play rugby 7 d6 is
coming in with 2 2 connected past points
on the 6th rank this is a winning
position for white so on and missed
rook to see one here he played the g3
first maybe he thought about rook the c1
on the next move the problem is after
rook a5 you can no longer play rook c1
as the knight here would be hanging so
here Anand first defended but now kiri
finds f6 and now the same idea no longer
works because after roof c1 captures
only 5 first D captors in g5 yes you can
go rook C to e7 but black now has g4
this is the difference now if you move
the knight then the rhudi to check if
you capture on e7 then you get captures
with checking if one rogue d1 check
you're gonna go kink the f2 room D to
check King to e3 and now f2 preparing to
bring your queen into the game but after
Luke after
seven it doesn't matter what black does
black will not be able to win because
there's always the threat of checkmate
you can just play King g8 here and after
white moves the rook go back and and so
on it doesn't even work if you want to
pick up a night with check because after
King Teti for the rook is under attack
and you moved you can prevent both
threats this mate and this mate
so with would best play it would it
would definitely be great for white
so after this f6 idea
we've looked he won so that's why now it
doesn't work here but you know it would
be a draw rook to e1 by Anand F captures
on e5 d captures on e5 and now h5 with
ecigs by Anand now it's a very strong
point but it can also be a very weak
point depending on what happens with g5
by black and now comes Luke to e2 we
have looked the d6 going after the d6
pawn and now h3g for we trade a pair of
points H gaffer's H captures and the
night the h4 threatening Knights the g6
check to become the bishop so look the
g5 defending and now rook to e7 another
wants to go to the fourth rank although
he doesn't want to rugby for since the
bishop is kind of controlling the be
Foursquare King yet now comes Luke to a4
and rook the d3 with rook to e8 check
Giri of course blocks and look back to
a-1 with rook B to d5 sorry that's rubgy
to d5 rogon D to D 5 and now comes Luke
to F 2 we have Russia back to d8 and now
rook to e8 so still not clear on how to
improve on your extra pawn with King to
e7 now going after the pawn rookie to
defending we've looked the c5 and now
comes look to a6 defending here again
not allowing rook rook the c6 to attack
the pawn with rook back to a rook 285
now offering a trade look the c6 and
rook a to d5 and here
rook to F 2 we have looked back to d6
offering a trade with rook captures King
captures and now Rudy to check if King
captures then you lose the bishop on d8
saw rook to d5 with rook after sandy
five King captors and Knight to f5 now
but there is no saving the pawn king
captors any success played Knights the
e3 now you cannot go after the pawn but
Geary just plays Bishop to c7 of course
Knight captures energy for n here after
Bishop captures and g3 the players agree
to a draw as now it is a draw after King
captures a draw by insufficient material
so very exciting game a lot of things
happening first Geary's counter-attack
on the Queen side in the center yet then
Islands attack on the King side then a
couple of missed chances and in the end
well are well fought to draw up until
the end I mean I draw by insufficient
material means there was it was a good
game
yeah now that's the game from round six
all the other games from round six were
also drawn so there is no change in the
standings were not even going to show it
although maybe maybe just a glimpse it's
eye
oh sorry about that it's the same one
I've shown you in the previous video so
nothing different there everyone has a
half a point more but I didn't update
the table but the stands are the same
but yeah I would like to thank Val
person and Matthew Heath Mario and sin
awesome mr. Amy Cogan and Ian Hayes for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos your
think all for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
sinful cup continuing the Capablanca
saga and finishing it and of course
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your weekend